[Music]
on this friday night canada stands its
ground
how ottawa intends to retaliate against
our closest ally
after president trump reimposes tariffs
on canadian aluminum
we will not escalate and
we will not back down jobs in canada
picking up
a new snapshot tonight that's positive
but not back to pre-pandemic levels
what's just happened to canada's last
fully intact ice shelf
as the arctic heats up it's now on the
order of 5
10 degrees or more and fears a huge
glacier in the italian alps could
collapse
at any moment plus play of the day
a bag snatching boar versus a man who
left nothing to the imagination
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
canada's deputy prime minister says this
country will not back down
after being dragged into a trade dispute
accused by the u.s president
of taking advantage of americans
christian freeland promised swift
retaliation today after donald trump
announced plans to reimpose
a 10 percent tariff on canadian aluminum
trump justified the move by saying
canadian aluminum imports pose a threat
to america's national security
freeland today called that ludicrous she
says the tariff is unnecessary
unwarranted and
entirely unacceptable
in imposing these tariffs the united
states
has taken the absurd decision to harm
its own people at a time when its
economy
is suffering the deepest crisis since
the great depression
freeland intends to impose dollar for
dollar counter measures
in our top story tonight michael couture
looks at why trump is picking this fight
now
and how canada is fighting back
canada will respond swiftly and strongly
canada and the united states are back at
it renewing
a tariff tit for tat over aluminum cusma
or the new nafta deal came into effect a
month ago
and was supposed to be a step towards
trade peace with our largest trading
partner
instead canada is making a list of
american products
to hit back the final tariffs that we
impose
will be as i said perfectly reciprocal
dollar for dollar and the total amount
will be 3.6 billion dollars
those tariffs must be on things
containing aluminum that's part of our
new trade agreement
we can't copy the 2018 playbook when
canada targeted products
from republican states like kentucky
bourbon
so when you look at our options there
you know what we're going to do put a
tariff on bottle caps
the government already has a broad list
it wants to narrow down which includes
home appliances
golf clubs and wheel rims and it's
looking to canadians to submit feedback
for the final list we're supposed to be
you know part of the big family and he
comes and backstabs us like this
ontario premier doug ford supports
slapping tariffs on american products
but he's got his own
protectionist plan we're team canada get
out there and buy ontario made
products we will kick their butts all
over the place 17 billion dollars
the provinces are important in this
fight especially quebec
home to nine aluminum smelters
provincial officials there
are already reaching out to their
cross-border counterparts
they like to buy the quebec green
aluminum and actually when i spoke to
i spoke to three states the governor or
or
or security of states i think they all
support but the key is trying to
convince president trump
who's looking for a win in the so-called
rust belt as the u.s election looms
he's grasping for something i think to
try to get
this connection with blue-collar voters
in particular areas and
unfortunately he's making it worse and
now canada has to once again perform the
delicate dance of pushing back against
the u.s
president without escalating the fight
donna mike look a tour in ottawa thanks
there is some promising news tonight
about canada's labor market
jobs lost at the start of the pandemic
appear to be slowly coming back and
at a higher rate than economists had
predicted there's still a long way to go
though to a full recovery
canada added 419 000 new jobs in july
that pushed the unemployment rate down
to 10.9 percent for the first time
statistics canada collected unemployment
data according to race
as eric sorenson explains it provides a
fuller picture of who his hardest hit
by the changes in the job market from
empty streets and an economic standstill
in the spring
to bustling cafes and a reawakened
economy this summer
the pint sports bar reopened bringing
back more than 20 employees
but it's still down from more than a
hundred workers because tourism has not
bounced back
and many weekday customers are still
working from home this is a problem that
a lot of us are facing right
it doesn't truly matter how much space
you have to trade
in if there are no guests to serve in an
economy still struggling most jobs added
were part-time
women and visible minorities have felt
the brunt and more than a million
full-time jobs have not come back
but the labor market is still very weak
the point of fact is that you still have
1.3 million workers that lost their
job during the downturn that weren't
replaced when the reopening occurred
the vast majority of jobs lost in 2020
have been a result of the pandemic and
you can see the pattern the number of
cases of covet 19 climbed from february
to march and they began
spiking in april and may to well over a
thousand cases per day
before falling off in june and july it
is from that virus that came the
economic flu
the number of unemployed started in
february around 1 million
climbed to a million and a half in march
and then peaked at well over two and a
half million
in april into may and then it began to
drop in june
by july more than four hundred thousand
fewer canadians were out of work
than there were in may the worry is that
when schools reopen and winter flu
season arrives a second wave of covet 19
could hit
and so could a second wave of
unemployment public health
education and economics are all
intimately intertwined
job statistics and income in general is
hinging on our ability to address public
health emergencies
and all that is kind of founded by the
ability to open schools so education
comes into this as well epidemiologists
and economists alike
are watching the same public health data
the virus is still in circulation
and i think this is going to temper the
pace of economic recovery
bottom line for canadians job numbers
may slowly continue to go
up if we keep the number of coveted 19
cases down
eric sorensen global news toronto
in the u.s the economy is on a roller
coaster ride the u.s gained 1.8 million
jobs in july as public health
restrictions were reintroduced in some
places closing businesses for a second
time
it's a lot fewer than the 4.8 million
jobs that were added
in june tens of millions of americans
are still out of work and lawmakers
can't agree on an economic relief
stimulus bill as jennifer johnson
reports america's unemployment rate is
still over 10 percent
as the coven 19 pandemic keeps
tightening its grip on the economy
the u.s labor department reports job
gains in july
were less than half the gains reported
in june
a deceleration some economists feared
it's a slow down and that slowdown is
completely related to the surge in virus
in the south and west as a lot of
municipalities started to slow down the
reopening process
millions of out of work americans are in
desperate need of more economic help
but the two sides in congress are still
wide apart on any long-term plan
the republicans have proposed a 1
trillion relief package
the democrats plan is over 3 trillion
but they say they're willing to
compromise
if we could do that if we take down a
trillion and they add a trillion we'll
be within range
pandemic unemployment benefits have run
out for more than 30 million americans
the paycheck protection program to help
small businesses pay employees
expires saturday and an eviction
moratorium
expired last week let's say if i can't
pay my rent they're going to kick me out
right and i just don't want to live on
the street
democrats want the unemployed to
continue to get an additional 600
dollars a week
republicans want to trim that amount
late friday no deal was reached the
white house says president trump is
ready to sign executive orders
to give americans some relief we agree
with the speaker this is not the first
choice
but people have run out of the enhanced
unemployment so that is something we
will recommend an executive order on
it relates to rental foreclosures we
will recommend
a executive order on that and also
student loans
both sides agree tens of millions of
americans are hurting
with bills mounting rent and mortgages
due and coven 19
forcing businesses across the country to
stay closed
jennifer johnson global news washington
tick tock is threatening legal action
against the u.s after president trump
said he intends to ban american
companies from doing business
with the chinese app the u.s president
issued executive orders to ban u.s
transactions with tick tock and with the
social media platform
wechat it's supposed to happen in 45
days
the trump administration says it's
stepping up efforts to purge what it
calls
untrusted chinese apps from u.s networks
in a statement tick tock says
we will pursue all remedies available to
us in order to ensure that the rule of
law is not discarded
microsoft has confirmed it's interested
in buying part of the tick tock platform
that operates
outside china another canadian the
second in two days has been sentenced to
death in china
yi zhenwei has been found guilty of
manufacturing and transporting illegal
drugs
this is how canada's deputy prime
minister christian freeland reacted
to the death sentence we oppose it
clearly and always everywhere
around the world we believe it is
a cruel and inhumane punishment
and we make that clear to all of our
interlocutors
everywhere we have made that clear in
our conversations with china
and we will continue to do so
four canadian citizens are now on death
row in china and
two others being held on espionage
charges face lengthy prison terms if
they are convicted
we're learning more tonight about the
man who in a lawsuit alleges the crown
prince of saudi arabia sent a hit squad
to canada to kill him
zad al-jabri is a former top saudi
intelligence chief who now lives in
exile in canada
for years he was a key player in saudi
arabia's national security
and had close relationships with the
so-called five eyes intelligence
agencies
he was also the right-hand man to crown
prince mohammed bin nayef
but in 2017 ben nyev's rival muhammad
bin salman took over running the country
and al jabri fled to turkey then to
toronto where he now lives
in a civil suit filed in the u.s al
jabri accuses bin salman of sending a
hit squad to canada
in 2018 to kill him former canadian
ambassador to saudi arabia dennis horak
calls it an extraordinary allegation
the obligations are certainly disturbing
and it's and it's something i think that
the government would look into
and and reach out to the saudis and find
out uh you know
what their perspective on this is
obviously they'll deny it and again
these
allegations to deal still need to be
proven in court but
certainly i think it's something that
should be concerning for canadians that
this could have happened on canadian
soil
canada's public safety minister bill
blair won't comment
directly on the allegations made in the
lawsuit but he does say ottawa will not
tolerate
foreign actors threatening anyone in
canada the saudi government has not
formally commented on al-jabri either
but has
tried unsuccessfully to have him
extradited on corruption charges
through interpol at least 16 people are
dead after an air india express plane
skidded off the runway as it landed
and split in half
this video from the tarmac shows the
front of the fuselage of the boeing 737
sheared off the plane was arriving from
dubai bringing home people who'd been
stranded abroad because of the pandemic
according to local media reports it was
trying to land in heavy rain when it
overshot the runway and crashed nose
first down a slope
190 people were on board including 10
infants
and among the 16 dead are the pilot and
co-pilot
there are troubling new allegations
tonight about that deadly port explosion
in beirut
sources have told the guardian newspaper
that prior to the blast dozens of bags
of fireworks were being stored in the
same warehouse
as that stockpile of ammonium nitrate
which acts as an accelerant in a fire
in video from the day of the blast you
can see white flashes what appear to be
fireworks going off
before the massive explosion
[Music]
a former port worker told the guardian
newspaper he warned for years it was a
disaster waiting to happen
and says nothing was done more than 150
people are now confirmed to have died
and there's a growing consensus in
beirut
that government negligence is to blame
lebanon's president says the cause is
still unknown
and as crystal gamansing reports he's
hinting without providing any evidence
of something more nefarious than
negligence
scorched and twisted metal as far as the
eye can see
this is what international search crews
are facing
questions about the cause of the
devastation and destruction
taking a new turn the lebanese president
is now
adding the possibility of a missile or
bomb
asking france for satellite help to
determine if there were warplanes in the
air at the time
michelle own says the cause has not yet
been determined
and that the international community
doesn't need to get involved
emotions are raw in beirut there have
been small but violent clashes between
citizens and government security forces
many say the explosion is just the
latest example of years of mismanagement
and neglect the blast involved more than
2 700 tons of ammonium nitrate
stored at the port boris prakashev was
the captain of the
ship that brought that load into beirut
during an unscheduled stop
he says the government knew it was
dangerous
now i cannot understand the fact that
the cargo has been stored there for such
a long time he
says he questions why it wasn't moved
and at least used to fertilize some
fields
there are grave concerns about food
security and shelter
aid distribution is now in full swing
with large swathes of beirut unfit to
live in
the country's principal port all but
destroyed
and the health system on its knees the
situation is
really dire it is so dire that even
support agencies such as the world food
program and unicef
are having to salvage supplies and take
stock of what's needed
international search crews are at the
site combing through the debris
with time running out to find any
survivors
krystal gavinson global news london
standing by his back to school plan
coming up ontario's premier takes on
concerns about
class size
with september approaching anxiety is
building about what happens when schools
reopen among the concerns is class size
in ontario more than one hundred
thousand people have now signed a
petition
calling for smaller classes the
government plans to keep elementary
school class sizes at pre-pandemic
levels
and today ontario's premier was asked
repeatedly if his government is open to
the idea of reducing class sizes
this is what he said we're giving the
boards 30
million dollars to hire new staff more
staff equals smaller classrooms
we're flexible we have to be flexible we
have to be adaptable
and my number one concern is to protect
the children
and make sure the parents feel
comfortable and we do have the best plan
we have the best plan bar none across
the country
premier ford admits keeping all kids in
class at least two meters apart
won't always be possible in manitoba the
province's second largest city is
dealing with an
outbreak of covid19 manitoba's chief
public health officer announced
17 new cases today and he confirmed
eight involved workers
at a brandon business he didn't name the
company but the united food and
commercial workers union has confirmed
eight workers at the city's
maple leaf pork processing plant have
tested positive for covid19
it's believed they contracted the virus
outside of work
still ahead how canada's last intact ice
shelf has changed
forever
fears are rising in italy as a heat wave
takes its toll on a glacier
in the italian alps dozens of people
near the popular tourist destination
of montblanc have been told to leave
because it's feared
the 500 000 square meters of ice could
collapse and threaten homes nearby
experts say the potential for collapse
was first discovered in april and
rising temperatures and another recent
fracture have greatly increased
the risk
canada's last fully intact ice shelf has
also become a casualty of climate change
the milne ice shelf is about as far
north as you can get it collapsed
into the sea last week losing nearly
half of its total area
as heather urex west explains
researchers say its demise
should be a wake-up call it's a
beautiful but remote part of canada's
arctic
that an ottawa research team has been
studying closely for years
this year's trip was canceled because of
the pandemic and there won't be another
chance to go back
i enjoy going there every summer and
to get news that that this piece has
broken off and and my
uh my study site has has changed
completely was certainly a bit of a
shock
the milan ice shelf is at the northern
tip of nunavut's ellsmere island
over two days in late july 40 of the ice
shelf
collapsed shrinking by about 80 square
kilometers
an area two-thirds the size of vancouver
these are huge areas of ice you spend
lots of time on to suddenly see it
disappear and that satellite images
kind of really bring us home how quickly
these changes are
nowhere has climate change become more
evident than the arctic
over the last three decades it has been
warming at twice the global
rate but this year summer temperatures
have been
particularly intense so we've seen
extensive melt
across the canadian arctic but also
elsewhere in the arctic in northern
greenland
in the norwegian arctic for example all
those regions have seen extensive
glacier losses this year given
temperature trends researchers expected
the ice shelf to collapse
just not so soon and not all at once had
coven 19 travel restrictions not been in
place the ottawa team would have been
camping on the ice shelf as it broke
apart
little changes in temperature year over
year
can unleash a very big response and
sudden response as this this event
illustrates another example of a
powerful consequence
that comes with a changing climate
heather urex west global news
calgary
what is going on here we explain a
strange scene that's all laughs and
no pants
some big news from britain palmerston is
retiring
he's been the resident cat at britain's
foreign office for four years
his age is uncertain but his ability to
write a resignation letter
is impressive he says he wanted more
time away from the limelight and he
signed it
with two paw prints palmerston who has
more than 100 000 followers on twitter
says he's done overhearing the
conversations of foreign dignitaries
he's had a few diplomatic disputes with
his neighbor larry the chief mouser at
10 downing street but larry being the
bigger cat is now wishing palmerston
well
there is another less dignified story
from berlin about a cheeky wild boar
and a naked man now don't worry it's
family friendly
the man who was sunbathing nude sprang
into action when a wild boar snatched a
bag holding his laptop
and ran off her piglets trailing behind
naturism is not unusual in germany but
board chasing is less common the man
eventually got his laptop back
locals got a good laugh and the whole
thing proves berlin is never
boring and that is global national for
this friday i'm donna friesen tonight's
here canada is fredericton near
brunswick
i'm off for a little break now hope all
of you get one too and i'll see you back
here soon
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye-bye
you